what is you know is that a power play
with with people's height and chairs
because Letterman always had that thing
that he had to be taller than his guests
I think for me it's just more like what
looks reasonable in life like because
I'm so short that onset a lot of times I
have to do things on an Apple box yeah
you know and then sometimes they don't
have the right height Apple box and then
it's like I shouldn't be the same height
as Shaq yeah that's not like a weird was
that it was that was a thing I won no I
did have to interview Shaq once and they
didn't give me an Apple box at all so it
was like funny to them that he was you
know a thousand feet taller than me if I
may complain about height for me I don't
ever I can never see my head in any like
standard mirror like a like a hotel
mirror or taller yeah I'm 6 foot 4 but I
so you should feel good but maybe you
can it can use maybe you can't know you
can see your whole body I can always see
my whole body interview that's a little
better 13 into drugs what an inch taller
than I am and less I kind of refused to
wear heels most of the time was that
because they hurt your foot hurt yeah
there I mean I'll wear them if I don't
have to walk too much but how did we as
a society make women do that what well
what is the heel all about well I think
a lot of women myself included we like
the way we look at them yeah they make
you like your asses all tight legs are
also me and you look really good and
your clothes and them but they hurt some
of them are really comfortable but wait
is the ass in everything although let's
get back to the ass is the ass all type
because you're in that like yeah x
position physics thing yeah yeah well I
should ask you that I know I should know
that's good but I absolutely duh when is
your birthday
my birthday is October 19th 1983 do
people usually say the year they don't
have to do women usually say the year
women have surprisingly been way cooler
with the year than some of the guys
that's funny because maybe because we're
in LA me yeah probably it also I am I'll
be 34 later this year Wow
yeah and I met you when I was
guest-hosting attack of the show but
this was maybe five maybe five six years
ago I don't even know if you remember
that must have been a really long time
ago was it towards the end when the show
was sort of like mostly guest host I
only get hired when that's towards the
end
that's that's how you can always tell if
I'm being hired Kevin had left the show
okay and they were doing all types of
guests host yeah I remember going on
once with Horatio sander yeah I think he
came on yeah and I forget what we talked
about but there was some it was some
cool thing but I've always enjoyed what
you're doing and pursuing in your
passions and how are we as a science
country right now Oh F F F - because of
because of Trump completely or how are
we doing with Obama - we were already
pretty bad
and I think that Trump like leaned into
the terrible I think that's really what
it was and it's not so much that we I
mean I think our educational system is
not where it should be
yeah but also my biggest concern and
complaint as somebody who works in
science media is that our science media
is abysmal yeah we don't prioritize we
really dumbed down all of our
programming I think Canada and the UK
especially but also a lot of other
European countries really have us beat
in that regard it it seems like in maybe
this is too cliche but it's like we
value the wrong characteristics in in
celebrity you know it's like saying
instead of oh my god they're amazing
like my kids that I don't have yep I'd
be afraid that they would rather be a
professional basketball player or
Kardashian than a world-renowned
scientist absolutely I mean if you think
about how we compensate people who do
different jobs in our country you know a
pro football player even not an amazing
pro football player I mean you've got to
be pretty amazing to be pro so I'm not
denigrating but sure might make a couple
million dollars a year and a teacher
makes like thirty five thousand dollars
each I know amazing but that being said
if we paid teachers like Wall Streeters
then we would get the wrong types of
people to become teachers now that's not
an argument to pay teachers [ __ ] yeah
I'm just saying I feel like there is
scholars migration in between there yeah
you should be able to yeah do we get
paid ninety five grand you know and be a
teacher or something who were your
heroes growing up I had lots of heroes
when my parents were awesome and they
really pushed me in academia I mean they
were
awesome in a thousand other ways but in
that way they were really awesome I had
some really good teachers growing up
when I was really young I was in a
gifted and talented program in my
hometown in Texas and my teacher her
name was actually Sally smart
she taught like the smart kids and I
think it was very smart I don't think
there's something to be said for the
name yeah I always wondered it for that
was like her real name it was I mean
that would be awesome if she changed her
name because she wanted to influence
children or something would be but it's
also very audacious yeah like yeah I'm
let's maybe you know smart in England
doesn't that mean like like snazzy
dresser yes what's she a snazzy dresser
I don't remember she was great Sally or
she's my elementary school and and then
I had a few other great teachers through
high school and then I had some great
female professors yes yeah it does seem
like we can name on one hand though
teachers that have influenced us
positively now maybe you have more
because you're in you're in the sciences
now I'm not but I can only think of like
three teachers that I like loved yeah no
I can't think of many when I was young
either I know the reason I have more
because I went to school for a really
long yeah like I just kept going to
school yeah yeah okay what we're birth
you grew up in Texas I grew up in Texas
okay and what we're birthdays like for
you there so here's the thing my
birthday I said October 19th yes
so my birthday has always been Halloween
Thea which is awesome if you had any
other guess of Halloween birthdays I
don't think we've had Halloween we've
had a lot of people that have had like
hey I get overshadowed by yeah because
this is the worst birthday right right
or I get when I had recently Melissa
McQueen it was its Kennedy's
assassination and I'm like Jesus twice
that's sucks yeah one of my best
friend's birthday is on September 12
yeah so like right like it was great
until 2001 and then everything went
downhill did something really bad
happened on September 12th or there are
the 11 yeah you're like are you [ __ ]
idiot like do a man on his facial across
so yeah so so what were in Jeb before we
get to the worst birthday wet in general
how were they free well they were
amazing because I have photos of my
first birthday ever and my mom baked me
a cake in the shape of a pumpkin and
everybody's dressed up in costumes
here's
thank you were fun people who have
birthdays that are close to holidays are
all always [ __ ] am i like a fox
because everyone they're always fun
because they are overshadows yeah if
it's a gift-giving holiday they get the
they get the two in one that's or just
crash or catch if it's like a
Thanksgiving nobody's in town if it's
you know some other crap holiday people
don't really pay attention to it sure
but Halloween is pure and simple a party
holiday yeah nobody leaves town they're
all where they live and they want to
hang out their friends and they want an
excuse to have a party anyway
and there's no you know unlike Christmas
or Hanukkah there's no like intense
religious obligation I mean even though
it's Manti religious yeah a lot like
Jehovah's Witnesses don't celebrate it
cuz it's Rick
horrible right is there a pagan history
of Halloween or something probably I
mean Aaron sound engineer saying yes
there is yeah I mean I've everything I
was like Dia de los Muertos
yeah I'm q8 and some of it spawned out
of this Day of the Dead thing so it's
like a celebration of death it it's a
sort of interesting it's evolved at
least in America but across the world
that's the other cool thing it's a
holiday that's around the world or who
like to party and dress up and you know
get get booze you have fun yeah I
thought what this holiday is absolutely
so from the time I was a child my
parents would throw me these parties and
we would have costume competition there
was a lot of candy and they would
actually convert my garage they were
poor cars out and they'd hang sheet
dividers and they would make a haunted
house for all my friends and then my
killer
yeah my sister and her friends would
like be the actors in the haunted house
it was really cool that's very cool yeah
and yeah and I could see that being like
it's not actually Halloween but it's a
few weeks before so let's get let's get
in the theme in the mood and other kids
coming in he usually round up right so
Arthur's the 19th so let's say that
weekend would be like the 24th oh yeah I
think so it was like a perfect day
because it was always the weekend right
before I never thought about that about
how we round up cuz if your birthday was
November 4th you would never throw
hahaha
yeah so we're they party yeah that would
be I don't know kind of obnoxious the
only thing I can relate to that is
people that have had birthdays on
July 4th or close it's like a fun
holiday yeah barbecue Holi barbecue
holiday exactly so what's a worse
birthday that happened in your life
so my worst birthday is not nearly as
bad as some of your guests worse yeah
but nobody had pretty weeks nobody died
right you know but you know what let's
end it yeah what he died nobody died
yeah I'm out uh uh um the worst early I
can remember involved an ex-boyfriend
then probably how we usually start them
I was living in Denton Texas I grew up
in Plano I went to college at the
University of North Texas which is in
Denton which is like the mini Austin of
North Texas okay whit see Texas is just
so big it's so big so Dallas is kind of
northeast yeah we call it like the
Golden Triangle area where I'm from so
it goes Dallas Fort Worth Denton okay
God and so I lived in Plano which is a
suburb of Dallas and then I went to
college in debt so it's like a 45-minute
Drive and all those cities are actually
people don't notice inside of the DFW
Airport if I go there for another Tyrell
and DFW is not in Dallas or Fort Worth
it's in Grapevine very weird it's kind
of in between that's no that's I feel
like that's typical where the airport's
not in the city proper Cincinnati
yeah no do you know does anybody know
this no it's in Kentucky yeah that's a
synthetic airports it's less acute than
whereas like Los Angeles Airport is even
Los Angeles it's like horrible not
necessarily I guess it's the worst
Airport so you're you're in Denton I'm
in Denton go I'm at this point working
on my master's degree so I'm working a
lot like I'm I worked in a neuroscience
lab where I am doing cell culture so my
job is to take a pregnant mouse every
year
Wow every week I don't know I said every
year ago this where they own them idea
every five every week sacrifice this
mama Mouse whoa take out her pups cut
off all their little pup heads and
that's that's what all pups
yeah they're called pups and how many
pups are in a mouse uh it depended maybe
like eight ten and these are tiny tiny
couldn't survive on their own and then
take basically my job was to culture the
brain tissue out of these fetal mice
well first time very hard the second
nobody at in this studio has ever said
anything
and self-assemble oh my god every week I
have to sacrifice this pregnant Mouse I
have to take these Mouse pup brains and
then I do this very delicate work under
the microscope and then delicate work in
a clean room like under event hood to
get this basically this brain tissue
played it you know complicated process
takes a few hours plated and then I keep
these these neuronal cell cultures alive
so we can do experiments on them
okay so let's pause there first because
first of all I always knew you were like
in science but this is real [ __ ] yeah
well almost everybody who's in science
does something I know but there's also
like the media science people and I
never really know if they're like did
real sign you know like it's like when
you know CNN has dr. oz and you're like
are you really a doctor I'm sure he is
but anyways he dr. oz is a real doctor
but he is very unethical on air but like
soon changes are real dr. oz it pisses
me off because he's like a really
respected surgeon but then he's like you
should try pushing this terrible ie
berries and they'll cure your cancer and
you're like oh my gosh and now you have
to go to a Senate hearing because you're
right here it's awesome
yeah like what are you doing but like
dr. Phil for examples of psychology sure
who lost his license so he's got hit the
hole right but you think they're - yeah
I feel like if people say doctor they
should have gone to either medical
school or got a PhD I didn't even finish
my PhD I dropped out of my PhD okay got
it
so I have a master's started PhD dropped
out actually going back to school in a
month are you really yeah because you
don't have enough stress on your plate
right now yeah so but so you're like
yeah well what what's your take well
while I have you here on this topic yeah
you're you're killing animals to to
learn about I mean what's your take on
this because I animal research yeah I'm
very Pro animal research but I do have
my limits it's actually an interesting
ethical debate that I like to have with
people who are like a hardcore PETA
supporters relation under no
circumstances I used to do the research
and I had friends who are like can't you
just you do it on the computer right
like not can't you can't you to take the
virtual mouse right and I was like I'm
not teaching like freshman dissection
I'm just using the tissue for sign like
it's not two different things but I did
have to teach a lot of dissection but
anyway everybody has a line in the sand
sure
my line in the sand is probably at like
super charismatic megafauna so things
like apes I don't think we should be
doing evasive research on Ava and we've
actually really improved our legislation
we used to be the only country other
than the African nation of Gabon that
did an invasive research on eight just
USA and Gabon the two of us yeah so I
don't have to tell you guys about
goodbye medical ethics we've gotten
better in there so I wouldn't want to do
invasive research on dolphins or
elephants or any of these organisms that
we think of as being like higher
consciousness organisms sure and I think
behavioral research is okay because
they're treated with like really into
respect but mice standard model
organisms zebra finches zebra fishes
there are a lot of organisms you use in
science that but like for you
where's your line well I was just going
to say like I don't I haven't decided on
my line but to me it's all about the
importance of research and you're
putting if you're decapitating a mouse
to figure out which lipstick works yeah
[ __ ] that is [ __ ] but if you're
trying to solve
Parkinson's that's what we're working I
mean come like sorry I would even
sacrifice small children yeah no I mean
like like to me but is that a is that a
is that fair for me to have that
distinction and I think that in order to
get funding and in order to get approval
because there's really intense ethical
boundaries and regulations yeah you have
to prove that you're doing something
important right and what we did in my
lab not to like to to our own horn cuz I
million years ruin a lot of Mouse
research is one Mouse one experiment so
you know you do something behavioral
then you sacrifice the mouse and you
look at its brain that Mouse did it
service science since I used a fetal a
model I was able to seed 150 cell
cultures out of one pregnant Mouse
actually so that's 150 experiments so to
me I felt like we were conserving you
know the kind of spreading out the use
really well but so I talked to PETA
people and no known under no
circumstances and then I always ask them
well are you comfortable with a fruit
fly research and they're like oh yeah
it's a fruit fly like it's an animal I
got what point I know I know an animal
no I understand if you're like a
Buddhist monk and you don't kill a you
know
a cockroach like I really respect that
but also we'd be like in the Dark Ages
when it comes to biomedical research if
we couldn't kill cockroaches I would
challenge any monk to live in New York
City or my apartment over here in West
Hollywood and not kill them kill kill a
cockroach because they get real
comfortable how is how are the bugs in
West Hollywood right now well I'm
actually in Hollywood
Marg Mount Village area in here in
Hollywood before I was at Melrose in
Highland
okay so just east of you but but I'm in
I'm in poor people Hollywood but right
next to me is rich people Holly and
they're constantly renovating because
they have awesome money and every time
you you'd knock something down all the
roaches run to poor people actually like
Nona man yeah anyways I mean life is
tough yeah I was there and and the bugs
were okay but now I'm in Los Feliz yeah
and I'm like basically in the hills like
like one block away is Griffith Park
yeah and I love we have so many bugs but
in the best way possible yeah you go to
your like Instagram and Twitter page
it's all it's all bugs and weird stuff
and I'm afraid of some of the pictures
it's amazing you love it we have
orb-weaver spiders all over the house
and coyotes in the bed not like I mean
my favorite I love I love I have a
friend that this favorite blog is what's
that bug calm and I literally go to the
page in it I can't even look at it
but I would like to be better I like you
better okay so you're in Denton you're
solving Parkinson's single-handedly Cara
Santa Maria Valley Parkinson's through
mice what what what's happening on this
brothers birthday so so I'm there in the
lab I'm working I'd like to work late
because everybody's out of the lab and
they're not messing with my stuff and
it's just easier so I'm working late and
I also teach a night class and if I'm
working late and then I have to rush
over and teach intro bio I can't
remember I'm going to embellish the
story now because I can't walk exactly
what you're suppose I don't say I was
doing I was elbow deep in pig guts
because I was teaching dissection
we'll say that there's a nice formal and
smell that you can't get out of your
clothes
yeah I'm in it yeah I'm like where I
remember that from Toad at like in
seventh grade
absolutely same thing so working all day
I'm tired I'm you know bent over like my
back hurts and I smell like formalin
yeah and then in my boyfriend at the
time is living with me in my apartment
it so how old are you your post
undergrad right laughter but I was a I
was a little like I graduated really
young so I was made was 21 22 yeah I was
young and so I I come home I'm tired all
I want to do is eat a nice dinner it's
my birthday
so I didn't I try not try to manage my
expectations I didn't expect much I
didn't know if maybe he would have
cooked for me or maybe he was just
waiting for me to come home and we'd go
grab a bite at even like just a quick
easy like tex-mex or something I get
home
yep he's on the living-room floor with
paper spreader ever and textbooks just
everywhere like taking up half the thing
and he's eating Taco Bell oh no and I
was like do you see a master student he
was an undergrad and we were the same
age which I was like a year two behind
in school and he yeah and he's like I
have an exam tomorrow and I was like so
why didn't you study earlier like my
birthday what are we going to do and
he's like oh sorry
and that was my birthday that was it I
was at I like 100 right through or
something well I hold birthday what was
the was there a plan beforehand no and
see that's the thing I think people
don't like if you're in a relationship
mm-hmm a lot of people don't realize or
even if you're not the day of very some
importance even if it's kind of an
inconvenient day and you've decided oh
but it's a Tuesday night and nobody's
around the mullah and Saturday we're
going to get together with some friends
you should still do something on Tuesday
okay this is an interesting because I've
gotten in trouble for this yeah I'm not
doing something yeah yeah and I'll be
like it can be a simple flower I know
yeah and I look I think you learned this
stuff the hard way and here's the to me
the silver lining in your worst birthday
was we were young maybe this is maybe
from now on whatever he is is you guys
still together um first of all not only
are we not still together but a good
nice aside a good friend of mine Allie
ward you may know her kind of in the
comedy world but also in the science
communication were hilarious you know
people who are funny they tweet funny
things sure and I'm following her
Twitter one night and she tweets
something along and she worded it better
because she's funnyer than i am but
along the lines of like my worst
nightmare is watching my ex-boyfriend
shopping for a house
with his new wife on house hunters oh
and I texted her and I'm I'm like not
only did that happen to me yeah but it's
that guy ha ha ha so you guys dated wait
wait I'm missing some so we dated in
crachit the same / wait wait but Ally's
not talking about your ex no she just
randomly was like this would be my worst
nightmare and I'm like well then welcome
to my fucked-up head because it happened
to me like last year she I saw him on
house hunters shopping for a house with
his new way house hunters who are you
casting like that would be difficult was
that hard for you or having to know I
don't know he's still in Texas yeah ever
yeah yeah got help so what I was saying
was was yeah the birthday will be
Wednesday which ends up being an
impossible day for everybody schedules
of us yeah and so that I'll be like okay
Saturday let's do the thing and I'll do
a great Saturday but then Wednesday I'm
kind of like where'd he did your
birthday or orange he's like or it's
like yeah yeah yeah my birthday and it's
always there's a lot of worse birthdays
that involve
partnership yeah like people dropping
the ball yeah or you know depending on
how you look at it someone's
expectations being too high you
dissecting pregnant mice teaching a
class in intro biology and coming home
and thinking we could have a nice casual
dinner I don't think that's to hiding I
didn't so it was hot
I'm tired but I wanted a nice bite for
my birthday yeah you know it could have
been like I was like you could have
gotten me Taco Bell right like we could
that could have even been romantic in
some way or there's my burrito like oh
well we didn't know when you'd be home
I'd leave that crap in like okay yeah
all right have you had other significant
others do a great job on yeah my
boyfriend now is incredible we've been
together for like four or five years and
every birthday has been amazing and I
actually learned from him yeah so he's
he's a little older than me but doesn't
seem it very successful in his work he's
an executive at a media company and but
he's like covered in tattoos and listens
to death metal but it's like a really
like an executive guy sure and so it's
weird and he's really grumpy isn't like
the best posture and so for every
birthday he will invite his friends Oh
for like some lavish dinner and then he
pays for it all because I was like I
want to thank you for like putting up
with me this year yes and I really
appreciate that because I have friends
who have these crazy expectation it's
thirty dollars a person who have got to
come in you and it's like why am i yeah
I don't want to do I thought your
friends that like don't have money so I
really started to model my birthday's
after him so like last year there's a
place in Los Feliz it's the cutest place
and we give them a little plug before
called glaze fire I'm kind of like
paintin party or color remind but like
for grown-ups
yeah I do i OB and they only have cool
functional pottery that's like robots
and dinosaurs and one skull and
crossbones and Jeff yeah and so I like
rented out the space I I got a piece for
every person I had okay so I grew up in
Texas and I have like a sick like love
of Olive Garden it's like my nostalgic
like that's amazing growing up in
Michigan you know and when I finally
went to New York really and I went to a
real Italian restaurant I was like
where's the unlimited exactly I'm ready
I'm missing your nothing with so I
catered it I got Olive Garden came every
rate and then it's like it's fun yeah
you know I like to do that now on my
birthday and then everybody can show up
have a good time it doesn't cost them a
penny they feel like I'm thanking them
for being my friend and it's you know
it's because I don't want everybody's
birthday to feel like I'm going to a
goddamn wedding where it's like so much
effort and so much work just I think
everyone needs to ask themselves like do
you like feeling socially obligated and
the answer is no no and you want but if
if every year I get an invitation from
you to your birthday which I am open
tonight right yeah and it's like that's
just I know that's going to be fun yeah
and I'm not going to lose any money Zach
I'm not gonna feel like I have to pay
for half of your dinner I mean like they
I always get invited these bar things
and then you get there and it's like
we'd better buy him a shot it's like
[ __ ] do you like this isn't fun for
me and also if you noticed when a bunch
of friends get together for like a
dinner whether it's for a birthday or
not or at a bar and then at the end of
the night it comes time to split the
check the the responsible people end up
paying like a whole word extra dollar
it's like so now even though everybody
did the math yeah you're short like
three hundred dollars I was impossible I
always I always say to my friends at a
certain age let's say it's twenty eight
let's say thirty
you know the ignorance is no longer an
excuse I fully your 35 and you have a
job you can't be like I was too drunk I
forgot about paying no it's just that's
part of it now yeah so like how often do
you I mean and I get it because I have
friends who are like struggling actors
you know who literally no you know they
work at Starbucks don't make a lot of
money and I so first of all I don't want
to be like I'm having a night and first
we're going to go to a show and then and
it's like oh it's only 300 bucks a
person they're like so embarrassed
because it cancer but yeah first of all
that's a terrible thing to do to your
friends don't do that to us
yes the second of all if you are
somewhat successful and it's like don't
be such a cheap [ __ ]
like I agree you know I would completely
other save pages you know how you have
those friends who never offer to pay and
you're like you do you make more money
than me like how is this our thing a
great way to enjoy your birthday we've
set it on this many times as lower your
expectations and be with the small group
of people that actually love you and
care about you absolutely now a great
way we haven't said this before and I'm
you're you're bringing it to me a great
way to have a great big birthday is the
[ __ ] pay for it just pay for it I'm
like it's once a year and sometimes it
doesn't have to be that expensive yeah
my boyfriend this past year for his
birthday cuz again he's kind of grumpy
and likes keep I'm soft
he only we had ten people over at our
house but he heard a sushi chef what
like that a falafel option and he did
like one of those big boats and put all
the fish and people could say oh do you
have like a California or no I want an
avocado and you make it to order it's
amazing now I want to read to you a
worse birthday from from one of our
listeners okay and get your get your
take out of this is only something it's
very this is very simple but I want to
see if it brings back anything that's
ever happened to you so this is from
Rachel I don't know where she's from but
rate Rachel thank you for sharing your
worst birthday with me you guys you can
always email me Michael at Michael Kosta
comm or call leave a voicemail 909 five
to worst and share yours birthday but
this is from Rachel
three days before my birthday this year
I walk outside and see my motorcycle has
been stolen that was it that was the
only thing she said to me
that's a way worse birthday than my even
that one-liner it's not it's not
competitive but I do want to add you so
competitive
[ __ ] you Rachel no Rachel you win had we
ever had anything stolen from you I'm
not really I got friends who might in my
last department where I live that was
close to where you live now sure I had a
roommate and her bike that I bought her
for Christmas got stolen like a month
after that I got referred so it wasn't
really mine but it felt a little like it
was stolen from me yeah and it was
locked up in everything I have yeah
Hollywood if they're locked they'll
still get stolen horrible what would you
tell Rachel how would you tell Rachel to
enjoy that birthday I would tell her
that hopefully she was insured that
maybe with the insurance money she could
get a better motorcycle ego right oh
yeah you know how you like scratched up
at one time when you look like that you
know like how you're looking at my phone
like Rachel's Sunday yeah you you know
you know you did that matches down the
side so now you get a better motorcycle
with your insurance money
maybe the newer model that you had
wanted but you couldn't afford it yeah
there we go I think that's great let me
name from I want to thank you for
sharing your worst birthday we like to
finish with the best birthday I didn't
ask you this ahead of time there's
anything you can think of that that was
a great great birthday that you've had
in your life well so I think this I've
actually shared a couple I think my
birthday last year was really really fun
I think that I did a few more like that
here in Los Angeles where I had a nice
dinner or something invited all of the
people I didn't know that olive garden
would do such a thing
Olive Garden has power so what Olive
Garden do you go to I got even know if
there is an Olive Garden here in the
valley there is we're in Burbank right
now that everyone's like down the street
I I don't spend a lot of time aback
should have known yeah and now that I
live in Los Feliz I'm really close to
Glendale so there's an Oliver yeah no
host mates delivers Oliver great it's
amazing look um but yeah I am
remembering one particular birthday when
I was a kid and I already touched on the
little where my sister and her friends
dressed up and we're like did the
haunted house thing and it was so cute
you know you remember the pumpkin like
the plastic pumpkin carriers that you
used to go trick-or-treating so we had a
bunch of those and like one of them had
the grapes and it one had the like
cooked spaghetti and it was like I'm
here oh yeah yeah yeah and I never could
to do the grape
yeah my dad actually he's an engineer
and so he like rigged these pulley
systems in the ceiling of the garage so
when you would walk down one corridor a
ghost would fly at you it was so cool
and then we had a costume contest my
friend Nathan Stein won the costume
contest he was dressed as a mountain
climber this is how flat it is effective
but if you dress is a mountain climber
it's like mind blowing mind you yeah
yeah and it was it was I don't know it's
really special oh that's great a great
memory what what is something that I our
listeners anyone in the United States
can do to just further our education or
our knowledge or our appreciation of
science look at what can I do
like like next week one thing read one
book learn a serum what is there
anything that you would recommend I mean
you could my part you listen there is no
there's a lot of things that you can but
let's get support so I work on two
podcast actually my personal podcast is
called talk nerdy yeah every week I
interview a scientist it's one on one
for about an hour we shoot the [ __ ] we
keep it really conversational it's like
we're having coffee and lots of fun lots
of cool thing and every like so much
different science on the show okay last
week I had a really cool policy analyst
who works in climate science whether she
was fascinating I learned a lot about
the Alberta cold sands yeah and then you
know that's really good oil when we have
the recruit and dirty oil and terrible
yeah so yeah I learned a lot about that
in these tailings ponds and stuff but
then maybe another week I'll have I had
an astronaut on recently which was
freakin awesome you know it just really
runs the gamut so that's talk nerdy okay
and then I'm also one of the five
co-hosts or four co-hosts and then
there's a host of the skeptics guide to
the universe this is like a very popular
science podcast it sent around 12 years
I've only been on it the last two and we
we tell different science stories and
also really dive deep into skepticism
how to have a better [ __ ] detector
yes you know how not to get jobs so
important yeah yes it was always an
award our veg it was important now
there's the whole fake news component
be like yeah Bigfoot's not real and
maybe don't treat cancer with homeopathy
but now it's like also how can you trust
anything you read on the Internet the
president yeah exactly so that's those
two podcasts you will actually learn a
lot of science in a fun way I also do a
lot of TV I just am wrapping on season
two of Bill Nye saves the world cool
so as soon as that season comes out you
can catch me on there and you can learn
about science but I was hoping glad I
didn't even know that got renewed I was
hoping it was because I enjoyed him
enjoy what they're doing so that's
really so that's a lot of fun and then I
would say um read I think that's
something people don't do enough and you
don't have to read you don't have to
like read every article in Scientific
American and really stay up-to-date on
everything that's trending but like read
a book yeah you know what I mean yeah
and there's so I do many incredible
science books I'll tell you two of my
favorite ok Oliver Sacks okay he
influenced me to get into neuroscience
he recently passed away it was quite sad
but is a neurologist who writes these
clinical tales of crazy stuff that
happens when people get brain damage and
the way he writes it's like a novel well
page-turner
his best book is the man who mistook his
wife for a hat oh yeah I've heard about
this I highly recommend you read it okay
and then the other probably favorite
science book of mine is a stiff by Mary
Roach oh this is the book about I just
I've learned a lot of but well I've she
was on NPR was just yeah he's Frank
that's how I guess I heard about that's
just great death a lot II think what
happened to the body yeah it's one of
her earlier but she's written a bunch of
really incredible one since then like
packing for Mars and grunt and gulp and
I'll be pissed if it happens it's
basically a chronicle of she was a
reporter and she was asked to go do a
story on the body farm and it opened her
eyes into like what happens when you
donate your body to science we're now a
kid a medical cadavers I never could
ever what can they do with you and it's
fascinating yeah okay and she's such a
good writer so I highly recommend both
of those books that's a lot of good
information for everybody out there I
want to thank you for being on the worst
birthday podcast thank you for having
your podcast or excuse me your website
Cara Santa Maria
I'm Cara Santa Maria comm you guys you
can't get easier than that yeah she got
in early she has a really but thank you
very much and happy worst birthday -
thank you - okay perfect
great